everybody's got [ __ ] and nobody cares
about your [ __ ] they care about their
[ __ ] cuz everybody's got [ __ ]
so nobody cares about your [ __ ]
complaining go [ __ ] do something and
that's that mom doesn't come around like
a visible what I see with clarity like
my name is Gary stop I've been telling
you accounts of equity
I'm triple a given a pedigree Devine and
a pleasure my fantasy between the work
that I'm doing are the moving furniture
seven when you talk to an upcoming
entrepreneur and say they want to build
their brand how do they effectively
break through the overwhelming amount of
information and distortion that exists
out there
talented effort just nothing else by the
way there's nothing else than anything
how do I become a professional hockey
player talent and effort how do I become
a tremendous top 1% lawyer how was it
effort how do I become a phenomenal
mother how is an effort its how an
effort and what what I love about effort
and why I love hustle and now that has
become so cliche to me saying they would
work a little bit more now because I
just want people to get it it's
controllable you know like it's
controllable like you know it's
controllable and I'm obsessed with it
because the other parts not like I
wasn't born six foot seven and can run
like a cheetah I mean that's just the
punchline
you've got to it's a game of poker you
get a hand nobody's going to cry for you
about your hand nobody's going to say oh
it's terrible that you're not fast at
all or gorgeous of Talia Orkin sing it
is what it is
and now the only thing that can happen
is you can figure out how to navigate it
many have won in poker with not the best
hand
and that's how I think about it and so I
was given the things I was given and I'm
trying to maximize them and that's why I
talk a lot about self-awareness I could
wish I was something or I can realize I
am something and try to maximise on that
and that's I think I think what I've
done extremely well and why I preach it
immensely because it's quite practical
is I deployed enormous amounts of
humility and self-awareness and said
this is what I am I'm not going to play
for the Jets but maybe I can own them
and I honed those skills
I'm not to keep nails do it
thank you my friend record shop with
your social worker speak for the twenty
year old like what I could remember that
got into the hospital and six-year-old
lifeless not too late we're in the
middle there it's not too late
clearly and you've got to work your ass
off and you've got it like you know
what's crazy is when I give patients
advice to 20 year olds it you know
they've got their whole life in front of
them but they're but it's hard because
they want to prove and they're impatient
I visited when I give a 40 year old
patients advice which is the answer I'm
giving you it's not as fun because
you're like wait a minute though like
you know I've already been through a
couple chapters like I don't want to be
patient I've been patient you know uh by
the way what do you say I gave you my
sister zeros it's not too late guess
what that means patients like the
fundamental thing is this nothing good
has ever been built from scratch without
hard work and patience nothing and I
don't you know I think people are
confused about a snapchat or an
Instagram or Facebook or child star or
an NBA athlete at 18 yes point zero zero
zero one percent of us have this
miraculous event that creates all time
life impact and income impact in a very
short period of time but for the 99.999%
of the
there's one formula hard work patience
talent in that arena and then your
outcome is the mix of how good you are
at those precincts so you know but then
I mean look what else is there like show
me showing the other formula
show me the quick spam show me the
eight-week course that did it for you
like show me show me examples actually
called strategy here's the finish line I
actually mean it like I actually mean
that's the finish line like that's
actually what I want to happen and I'm
going to do my behaviors every single
day of my life because this is actually
what I hang on good
good morning but then I've got a little
bit of stomach thing which not weird hey
man good to see ya
hey Ben I hope he'll in it yeah hanging
in Megan him I like the pure Wow yes
yeah okay yeah my stomach was bothering
me but I think I'm gonna make it oh yeah
yeah yeah it's become real life hello
everyone hello I think you have to
execute against your truth people can
smell things you know I was there early
on with TOMS shoes and met Blake and
like he actually meant it like he
actually went there he's an entrepreneur
he's Osler but he actually felt like he
wanted to do that
then every single entrepreneur 2013 and
14 pitching me Gary I want to change the
world so here's how I'm going to do it
I'm going to raise a ton of money I'm
going to build a business I'm gonna make
a ton of money on but I'm going to give
a granola bar to every single kid every
time somebody buys a granola bar which I
doubled the price up so I can still keep
my margin yeah like this is my favor I'm
a businessman I love when people like
Gary I'm throwing granola bar company
but really I'm also one of these new-age
Millennials and I give a crap about the
world I'm like okay keep going Pat and
he goes yeah so here's my theory I'm
going to sell this granola bar it's
delicious I got the best chef ever this
granola bar and I'm going to then donate
a granola bar to the kids in Africa
because they're hungry okay keep going
Mel gonna do that then I'm like Pat I'm
looking at your business
why is your granola bar twice the price
of every granola bar oh I know why bad
because you want to keep all the money
from the first granola bar and the only
way you can give the other granola bars
if you double the price and subsidize
your donation you're full of [ __ ] pat
pat cost I've seen a million passes when
it comes from a true place you win and
when it doesn't you don't and by the way
are there one or two packs a generation
that sneak through the system and scam
it all the way through course but you
want to be Pat laying on your yacht in
the Caribbean one out of a trillion the
other trillion or looked as [ __ ]
[ __ ] faces not respected bad humans but
one path out of a trillion you actually
want to lay there and sleep at night and
realize what kind of dude you are sick
you are diseased Pat cause it could be
both so you know I mean that's just a
stupid game ninety nine nine nine nine
nine percent of you are going to be
deemed as not good one of the good drill
Ian gets through and you still got to
sleep at night stupid
I agree I agree man log on and house
Thank You them second family and before
you question cool guys thank you so much
you guys aren't coming out how we will
all be yellow coming young hi you're
like a blessing meet you thank you thank
you thank you honor yeah you know what
back that's the best that's why it works
that's why I love doing Q&A like people
don't do Q&A because they don't know
their [ __ ] right and they're scared of
questions I'm not scared of any question
like ask it like what people don't
understand is it's unfortunate then I
only like I stay in a very narrow lane
but I love when somebody asks me a
question I say I don't know you want to
really build trust say I don't know
especially because I have so much
bravado and what I like in my world I
really know so then when I get to say I
don't that's like Q&A so great either I
crush it or I say I don't know which are
both wins honest is the game man
game time loves it what is game time or
no
so what you were doing actually was your
intent was to look like a good person
but still making much money every dollar
that you would have it he didn't have
the [ __ ] model that you were
donating something and so when you were
completely full of [ __ ] [ __ ] so if
you want to actually accomplish the
thesis of this conference you need to
making sure that your intent is pure
your intent the way you make your money
the way you make your money is something
you're proud of
don't be full of [ __ ] because you're
tricking the 90% that don't matter and
you're using equity to the 10% that you
number to do it you got to work you feel
super inspired from this weekend you
can't wait what happens next Thursday
what happens next month you have to
actually work a lot you know zero people
zero people that have built something
big that haven't put in a ridiculous
amount of work and the bigger it is the
more they've worked so many of you have
your mouth way ahead of your actions
really you're going to own an island and
you [ __ ] go to Coachella [ __ ] you the
only people here want to be a
millionaire you know where that is have
you won the one you have this enormous
audacity you have this enormous audacity
yeah you're not putting in the work to
get you there because you think somehow
you've been tricked by yourself or
somebody else that there's some system
now there's some [ __ ] shortcut
there's no [ __ ] shortcut you got to
put in the work
lacks of it and that comes at the
expense of golfing all the time and that
comes at the expense of going to every
the vet and it definitely comes to the
expense of watching one more
motivational video and three more books
and seven more you have to view the way
to win is as old as time do the right
things and put in the [ __ ] work thank
you speed wins everything speed wins
everything speed is absolutely one of my
two or three religions in business speed
fast
everybody's too precious you're
overthinking your content you're
overthinking your decisions you're
better off doing sixteen times of being
right three times they're not doing
anything at all you're pondering you
lack the confidence because you're
worried about what people say I like
losing that's why this is all so easy I
don't give a [ __ ] if you said I lost I
kill true it's an important thing bro I
love your beard you're welcome um but
beard Uzair is reacting to the right
thing and I'll tell you why by not
worrying about what other people think
it allows you to do things by doing
things you either win or you learn from
your loss and it creates speed it's the
absolute mental difference between the
people that are executing the winning
versus the people that are the fear of
other I don't want to leave but I'm
definitely more disappointed than your
opinion in your blog post about my loss
oh no I got a throw pillow
all right fine that I go thank you oh my
go give a round flat down thank you
thank you
oh yeah okay oh my god
thank you oh there we go boy
thank you can I step outside video song
idolize like my house okay come on if I
make sure life is how do you help a
hundred thousand immigration after the
person's generation are doing minimum
wage job and I'm not even sorry times up
you can only teach people how to are ok
going back all the way over
oh my god sure scary this is unreal
thank you so much you're welcome so much
for coming I'm not to find a video same
and we're going to like each other but
it's against the human will yeah like
what are you gonna do like like her
Unipart like how are you gonna adversely
unwilling for forceful ones that are
capable because rich hard-working
immigrant elected in Iran John sure so
just starting like like you understand
unwilling come to the market yeah you'll
need permission from anybody to do it
yeah yeah you can't sit and dwell and
say hearing companies want to market to
12 to 18 year olds a hello you just need
to go ask every one of them to give you
money when I started like when I sort of
Bainer me and nobody wanted to do social
media marketing so I got and I had a big
name and I had a million followers on
Twitter and I built a big business
I had street cred and no no no no no no
no no no no yes but for a number but for
a number that I hated but I had a ticket
I had to take it for five thousand
dollars a month from
the biggest big companies and they want
to pay me less than they do for like the
stupidest [ __ ] on earth but I had a
ticket it doesn't matter what you want
it matters what they want you just need
to not dwell on it and just ask
everybody amazing you're welcome a talk
about the bra that I have under this
raise a family so that's why I'm being
like I want to be fair and say no but
I'm giving away my time in my community
like that how I'm doing it so like
whether it's 50 second club or randomly
just asking me an email it could happen
especially in today's environment where
so many people are living there like
it's way better for you to like take the
seven people that you want to be like or
admire and watch what they're doing then
read their book it's way smarter to
watch what I do every single day than it
is to read my book you know like we're
so lucky we get to watch people's
actions in public it's so powerful like
there's a reason I wanted you guys on my
Instagram story today that like hit the
notification bell on YouTube you should
understand what that means why did I do
that why do I care that way more than me
talking about it 14 months from now of
why I did it fresh thing everybody like
don't listen to what I'm saying watch
what I'm doing watch what I'm doing
watch what I'm doing like you know and
so and so there's more not you know what
do you think you're going to do like
there's there's nothing there's
unlimited motivation Oh speakers Frank
I'm not a motivational speaker I'm going
to save every single time I understand I
come off that way but it's what I'm
doing that's so much more important yeah
there's a lot of motivational speakers
that are the business to just make money
off people that don't want to do their
bottom-feeding
I don't want anybody that doesn't want
to do notice how I'm saying things that
nobody says like don't watch my content
they all want you to watch their content
so you can buy their course yeah like
what do you think's happening like
what's the matter with you guys like so
so I don't know what do you think I'm
going to do for your friends that want
to come to you like like if they're just
your if you have a business that you
want to sell to them to motivate them
well that's a different story but if
you're just trying to be something I can
change your policy I'm gonna tell you
something right now it is the worst
business in the world selling to
unmotivated people because your
bottom-feeding
that's why I don't do it I give the
right answers and then I hope you do
something about it but that's not where
I'm making my money I'm not making my
money on you everybody else is making
their money on you I'm not I don't like
that business people are selling to the
bottom 10% that's where they make all
their money the people that will never
do and will continue to buy every course
because they think some new person came
along and they unlocked it hey damn you
know the basics they figured it out I
will never sell to somebody who's not
fixable totally yeah you know I sure
feel welcome I joined to you later thank
you very much yes
stop bullshitting you're [ __ ] full of
something okay I take my confession from
my family the real question
Wilton I just got a quick picture how do
you talk a lot about it like
self-awareness how do you get your team
to be on that day level by giving them
everything they need
you work for a team that they don't work
for you oh yeah
how many how many have on your team
right now 15 and Counting it to 25 great
how many times have you sat down with
the 15 one-by-one for three hours and
ask them what do they care about in life
and how do you help them got it that's
fun yeah I guess the answer bro
like how the haters seem to care care
for them first you know you're worried
about 15 to 25 without getting 15 giving
them everything you got reason Vayner
got so big those first 15 I gave them is
everything at 800 gets harder every day
50 that you gave so much to to pick up
the pieces got it
you're 15 - 25 - 25 to 80 is going to be
irrelevant if you don't make these 15
feel like a [ __ ] me in the world view
and if you actually do for them what
matters to them at your own peril you
should leave yeah yeah I know I am so
[ __ ] now learn something else no but
like we don't know something I built it
for them but you want to give me a
partnership you so he departed it with
did you believe you're the bad spot
anything spot I was at Wine Library
I came here forever like a year now dude
it's all work but I'm telling you right
now
the quicker you move and let the poison
out and start forgiving
otherwise you'll be stuck forever where
you going you're kidding [ __ ] I can't
have that
well that's right but then you like it's
like then then you got it in you
you'll receive binary that's what's so
crazy about these hard life that they
have there's no half pregnant right
either either you're stuck just cuz that
happen in the beginning and you thought
it would work out like so many of those
things have gone wrong for me I can't
even family this I get it man so like so
like if your brother has control you've
got a problem well my dad started yet
it's done give it to him okay
here the government okay and then now
he's the boss which you should be as
awesome way bigger company okay and you
can mean my guy work long understood but
here's what I can do okay like to hit
long where I want still sell my shed
okay I'm the only one in the world I
know it's bad so that's a good start
like if you got like on the on the face
of the company well that's you're in a
great spot
so what do you sell air conditioning
great
can you cook Road great so like maybe
you have a non-compete no counseling you
can sort of hear my problems seem far
less silly now I know problems I don't
want to be here on a Saturday when my
family's not here I know problems but
guess what I mean my bed I'm making my
choices I got my reality every single
person here has [ __ ] all of you you all
have [ __ ] do the white dudes have it
better yes
guess what they still have [ __ ]
everybody's got [ __ ] and nobody cares
about your [ __ ] they care about their
[ __ ] because everybody's got [ __ ] so
nobody cares about your [ __ ]
complaining go [ __ ] do something and
that's it go green conferences and email
that you'll sleep for a bit
that's a daddy look at what you think
somebody's gonna come along do it oh
we're so sorry here we'll put you on
Saints little came here for a reason
you got it that's it alright it is my
present
good luck on drafting here thank you
all right thank you appreciated thank
you Hey several awesome yes that would
be amazing
thank you Vancouver that was good a lot
of fun felt really nice it's really the
manifestation of all my words you know
why you haven't had a deal with that
nobody's giving everybody's taking
that's it when you give you win
Thank You economy and jobs your driver a
hook will written back to back in the
middle of my storm for a reason
pay attention to the cadence of how I
wrote my books the rocks oh okay
Oh yau-man we're gonna fight let's do it
Shan Shan but my one question I never
play cuz I have to catch my family so I
have to really go go ahead
when does the more you draw the battle
become I thank you that is my favorite
the more you grow the more you like it
now
okay never waver from your engagement
matter what no matter what no worries by
cleaning it you grab all three what
about with a dream yeah nada
here with me and my wife okay four hours
they got so I got a real real quick
watch here invest in your business right
but when you were 20 yeah you were
starting out yes you can have a wiping
that's right
but you had to take the swim you still
have to break up that how do you don't
that's your reality do it you know to me
like like I don't care that I didn't
have that I have it now how do I do it
now like like do you make choices I
don't call my weekend to anything but I
did today I made a choice like you make
choices all right do you know what I
mean I do I do it like you can't want it
the way other people have it you wish
you a 22 and had unlimited who gives a
[ __ ] you have your reality you take in
the swimming and then nine hours you
have you do it like it is what it is
right
everybody can exactly like I have some
some of the greatest opportunities in my
career because my kid had a play other
times I said I'm going to go to this
thing I might get out of play you make
choices and you live with them alright
all right thank you what I want to do
though is essentially I want to have a
little company so I said what I want to
do or why is you want to save money yet
and learn learn different things these
different people look simple on what you
want to do you graduated college action
did what you supposed to cushion my
mistakes the Audion weapons earned the
title belt underworld champey here but
no one else knows it is biggest weight
has been going to it maybe on what you
saw is my career but it's a family day
maybe spring for a car payment for a
there's an assassin that I can't afford
to be late and I justify him by one
that's how we got there we believe in
what I believe which is result silver
bullet one restaurant at a time heart is
hard but what building the business and
certain causes I agree like why
shouldn't it be heart the other fans
that's what's so interesting to me
people like it's hard it's sitting on it
so who [ __ ] you better cause I we we
spend so much time on what we don't have
versus focusing on what we have and so
I'm honor Jetix because I'm grateful and
I'm happy and when you're happy like
everything quick and so I think I get my
energy from natural chemicals for sure
but other than that I would say
gratitude is my biggest driver for
energy and everybody needs to build a
trillion dollar business like maybe
you're at a place where you're like
please if you cool to sell crazy
stability gets in cash in a leash it for
a year or two and stay at the company
that buys me I've got other paintings
other ambitions other businesses I want
to build that's the sense I'm getting
that you're debating and I think that's
cool I think when you see consolidation
there's two things one winner is massive
consolidation there's opportunity
because a lot of the people that compete
with you are going to get beaten up and
then struck because they're part of big
things
for this your time to grow you might
also be tired bored or intrigued by
something else so this may be the time
for you to set hi I'm Rafi how are you
good I have a question
anyway it's possible that a full-time
job in Java successful business card but
yes I think you can start the foundation
for successful business eventually grow
yes you can of course like successful
likes house so I built my story business
for five years in that cosine I'm a
practicing attorney though
went back pressing law and that I would
do is decide what you want to do if you
want to run the jewelry reserve so wants
right so dubious for anything
save live more humbling like how much
are you I got it that's your only way
talking another action so if you really
want to do I'm a good night well I get
it took one more but you want to do with
jewelry thing what y'all think about I
want to give up my legal career but not
anyone I know what you want to do so you
have to give up the [ __ ] quick your
binding between them
on a serious note just good man
scuffling thriving reacting living
preciate guys being partners drumming so
please haha have to pee neo I said I
hate my job but I need this money